stern had approached us to use our
business model as a thesis for for one
of their semesters and I had worked with
them sort of on a weekly basis talking
about our business and it was it was
really interesting because we have a
very sort of non-traditional business
model in terms of how we've gone after
business from a niche perspective and as
an entrepreneur you know we didn't set
out in I think a manner for which many
entrepreneurs do it wasn't this okay
well we're going to start a business and
here it is and we know we're going to do
this it really just was a very simple
extension of things we already were
doing and we knew and we loved and and
it felt good because that we were very
passionate about I think that was
definitely you have to have you have to
really be willing to roll up your
sleeves and become a jack-of-all-trades
so to speak and in many ways that's a
great education because even as your
business grows and you start delineating
responsibilities other things you know
how to do every single job in an
organization but the but even in talking
to MBA students you know is this sort of
a win is there a time when you don't
need to get an MBA because you have so
much experience in your business that it
doesn't really matter it's not going to
take you to the next level and i think
that the time for starting this business
was then like we didn't need to have you
know in my opinion for what we were
doing we didn't necessarily feel we
needed to have the NBA to get us to be
here it was just really sort of natural
at that point so experience for me one
of the things that i always talk about
is having that that level of experience
on so many different from so many
different directions was really what i
think helped us be you know to get to
where they're it have to be tenacious
there's no question about it yeah
um well first of all we're partners in
life I mean although I guess that's not
totally untraditional I mean families
and couples have done that together but
I mean more specifically the model
itself like having written a business
plan which we had had some dear friends
who had started a quite a successful
business in Australia and I used their
business model there the business plan
to write a business plan which took me
probably about six months after i had
left prada and then another year in
development from start to finish when we
launched and the business itself is sort
of a non-traditional aspect of how to go
after business and what we've done is we
had set up sort of this this idea of a
freestanding store sort of being
everything for us it was the dust story
was the showroom it was our opportunity
to create sales it was our distribution
center everything to the brand so we
were sort of sitting in the store
waiting on customers packing boxes that
were being shipped to London it was
everything all encompassing and it sort
of grew organically from there we didn't
take investors we are self-funded we
have grown only organically the business
has been profitable since its first year
and it has been operational since its
first day so while we put in an initial
capital investment to the company we
haven't invested any more of our own
money since then we've only allowed it
to grow sort of naturally in its own
direction yeah I think that's actually
the thing that's the most untraditional
is that we haven't had a very slick
marketing world that everything has
grown organically and that we don't
actually go after business in a
traditional way the matter of fact we
have never solicited any of our accounts
so everything has sort of come to us and
I think that's what a you like it
let its left us very exclusive and
having had sort of these backgrounds
where we were taking experience we had
you know I had many beauty editors who
knew who I you know who I was and what I
was doing and Andrew had design editors
and so we already had sort of a built-in
platform with those I had had
experienced you in retail distribution
so there were sir
number of retailers who already knew me
and would talk to us about our brand so
in all respects we had sort of set the
stage in sort of a non traditional
manner with basically no money so if
that answers the question